ating the details to others and that's
why I'm especially interested to hear
more about the information sharing
aspect of the N2 directive but I have
also some challenging questions
hopefully if we have time but before we
go into more uh details I want to
introduce you to the member of the
European Parliament B guus from the
Netherlands he is the repur of the nis2
directive and he will answer all my
questions so welcome Mr guus thank you
so much for your time and maybe you
could briefly start
this
he's offline I can't see
anything
that's concerning maybe in
well okay we'll report it
responsibly okay what was your question
yeah so let me start with a hopefully
easy question that apparently somebody
doesn't want you to answer what even is
n to can you briefly describe the scope
and why it is important well it's
Europe's Flagship on cyber security
regulations and and and laws and it's
the successor of nis1 which was the
first time that Europe tried to do
something over all member states to
regulate cyber security many member
states were extremely reluctant and they
didn't want to but it's like planting a
flag like a colonizing America this is
my land and now I have something to say
and from there you build and this is
what Europe sometimes does and I think
on cyber security it's very wise the
basic of it all is the the internal
market so if you do business you have I
don't know manufacturing companies in
Romania the Netherlands Germany and
Italy you're being treated the same
which is very nice and so we've created
um better regulations for cyber security
that entities especially should protect
themselves better as we spend 41% Fabian
41% less than our American colleagues
and this is like you know it's a water
bed effect heckers go where the
resilience is least and Europe is being
hit harder than many other continents
and that's what we were worried about so
we created the NIS
2 so uh
you uh you you already mentioned uh that
it's about um
uh I'm so sorry this yeah okay I have to
apologize I'm extremely nervous because
I've never done this uh something like
this before I'm a nerdy Hecker sitting
in my dog room usually so I'm getting a
bit stumbled here um but when I when
when reading the introduction of the NIS
um directive one of the first words and
what is apparently the driving Factor
behind it is that it's to improve the
cyber security capabilities within
Europe and I've been wondering like what
even are the cyber security um
capabilities you also mentioned that um
the member countries were quite
reluctant to adopt this so what is it
cyber security capabilities seem
reasonable to implement what is what are
they reluctant about well they're
reluctant about cyber security like I
say it's a member State competence a
national competence we will deal with it
ourselves that's what member states said
but now they see like if we share
information better and we can create an
ecosystem for example for indicators of
compromise after during an attack even
before an attack that's interesting so
we try to make a new legal basis to
share information and if you ask me I
come from this cyber security Community
just like you and uh when I became
legislator I thought what is my res in
good German right uh why do I get up and
I get up to make the cyber security
Community feel like this is going better
and one of the things that we saw is we
it was hampered like the sharing of
information was hampered by the gdpr
right many people felt there could be um
uh um uh reluctancy because there might
be personal data in an email address an
IP address can you share that with
others it might help somebody else but I
might get a fine for it as well that's
what we try to decide we set the record
straight you have a responsibility to
share information and it's not just
about passively sharing data it's about
actively so this is the second phase the
nis2 of Europe cyber security
Consciousness the awareness of
Consciousness not just passively sharing
information after an incident but even
before incidents occur doing something
about it we want eventually this
ecosystem to be the basis of protective
DNS for example why don't we flag
malware domains and make people aware
that if you click on this false email
you get a red screen saying this might
be something you don't want this is
probably malware it's a free country
click if you want but this is not the
way that you want to be served you're
being fooled and this is something we
could actually do something actively
protective DNS warning initial
ransomware victims this this is
something that we really
want as you mentioned the sharing of
incidents is very important and integral
to this directive and I've been actually
it sounds like maybe a dumb question but
what even is an a cyber security
incident do you have some examples of
what could be well if you want to
legally Define that that's very
difficult so we tried we tried to Define
that in a significant incident meaning
it has significant effects on the in a
sense essential services that an entity
that's difficult legal let me rephrase
that for anyone that can follow we used
to have vital entities vital
infrastructure it was water energy
Telecom that's it now we are creating
more than 160,000 entities across Europe
also hospitals great manufacturers large
companies but also Banking and Financial
sectors and why the philosophy the
philosophy behind it is because those
offer essential services to our citizens
that's very different than before and
it's very aligned with the business
model of hackers right if you have a
Russian ransomware group they don't
watch is it water is it Telco or is it
energy no then we won't touch it they
touch whatever they think can benefit
them and the number of incidents
significant incidents in Europe in 2019
in my home country doubled in the
Netherlands the FBI reported on 2020
that the number of ransomware incidents
significant incidence tripled in 2020
that number has grown in 2021 Etc so we
have a problem and what we do now is
entities not just the critical vital
infrastructure from the old days but
also new vital infrastructure like
hospitals to protect themselves better
yeah um according to the nis2 briefing U
quoting some numbers it was that
according to Verizon 86% of the breaches
were financially motivated while only
10% were espionage you mentioned
ransomware which is a typical cyber
crime operation with financial
motivation do you think n is able to
capture the cyber crime World um as well
as the Espionage do you see a certain
Focus where n is helping well let's
start with the high end right with n
nation state actors with Advanced uh
actors coming coming at you and it's
always a question of how much time and
effort would someone put in to get in
and if you if you're a nation state and
you have significant amount of resources
eventually they might get very far but
you can hideen the cost for them for
average businesses or for those
businesses you really want to protect
and what we've tried to do is make a
risk based approach that we would say
some manufacturers are in the scope say
you're vital infrastructure now but if
you produce cookies I don't mean the
cookies you look after but I read
cookies you can eat for example you have
you don't have that high risk profile as
you as you are probably asml right in
the Netherlands that's a nation state
magnet a hive where the Chinese would go
and Hunt whatever they can get their
hands on it's fine and they will do
everything so what we try to do is
heighten the barrier and do something
about it the second thing I'd like to
say is if you look at ransomware and the
the nature of ransomware and nation
state of tax they've merged in the past
years what we see many Russian Russian
speaking russian-based ideologists and
Main CEOs behind are Russian Russian R
ransomware attacks are also an
instrument of the Kremlin as a foreign
policy
instrument weakening the societal but
especially the economic Fabric and
structure of Europe is actually
something the Kremlin wants to uh to to
achieve in its foreign policy goals it's
melting together and if you would look
at for example Colonial pip P lines
maybe we can remember in the um east
coast of the Americas the United States
a large pipeline was damaged by a
ransomware attack it couldn't deliver
gasoline and the prices went up very
quick if you would look at the
ransomware and I do that just like you I
and if you look at it if you decompile
the the code it wouldn't have gone live
if a Russian keyboard was attached of it
was it would have Russian uh time um um
meeting so it it wasn't meant for
Russian speaking audiences it's meant to
weaken the West this is exactly how
technical artifacts lead to this ass
assessment and that's what we tried to
legislate as well yeah you mentioned
risk is as a core word even if you
search in a directive for the word risk
it appears 100 over hundred of times so
risk management is a core Principle as
it seems in this directive and uh if we
look at quoting again uh the the data in
the briefing it says that 45 of breaches
featured hacking while 177% involved
malware and 22% involveed fishing or
other means it shows that hacking with
real vulnerability so to say is the
minority the majority is a human factor
and a human factor that's a risk factor
so I want to I was wondering like how
does n handle the difference between
vulnerabilities that can actually
discovered and be fixed and this human
factor which is is and will probably
always be inherently risky to some
degree what you say inherently risky is
good to recognize if if I'm very
critical Fabian let me let me
AER not much of what we do around the
world on cyber security is actually data
driven right we don't have the right
data to say how preventive measures to
mitigate the weakness of us humans and
training Etc and preventive meas how
that helps to mitigate cyber threats
I sometimes click on fishing emails and
I'm trained I I do it and uh that's why
I think you have to solve it technically
so this law does
not it's probably good to do something
about prevention and awareness training
but that's I'm not saying it's wrong but
what I'm saying is you should do
something technically to prevent people
from infecting their machines by
clicking on wrong emails it's much more
effective and that data drivenness that
I want to see more in future legislation
and I I think that National cyber
security centers have a big
responsibility there the Sears like we
call them need to gather that data and
we need to be more data driven as we
make policy in cyber security if you
look at the NCC UK they've said the same
they we're all looking for the same data
what is actually working what is
not you mentioned uh data driven
approach and having read a little bit
over the N directive um it's important
that companies need to uh report on
incidents yeah I feel like uh this kind
of data that is then collected better
understanding the threat landscape and
the kind of incidents uh that appear
might also help us to identify what are
even the critical systems softwares and
products that are being targeted have
you ever thought about uh using this
kind of data collected in somewhat kind
of like a European bu Bounty I imagine
like a a list uh published by by Europe
these are the critical infrastructures
and we have a budget assigned and we
allow hackers like me to freely look for
vulnerabilities reported and and so
forth well I thought about it a lot V
but there wasn't a majority to do
something about it yet but like I said
we planted a flag now we see what can we
can do more but if you look for example
in the UK there's a government program
an active cyber defense program running
agents on the majority of government
computers and their top sectors um that
to economic sectors and what they do
they can those agents can can identify
what software is on every platform so
whenever you have a critical
vulnerability somewhere you can identify
where is that where is that software and
in in what which parts of the essential
and vital critical infrastructure that
we have is that that's something that
the majority of the countries does not
yet have would I like to see that yes in
future that's definitely something we
would have to work on sure but um the
same goes for for example another
Innovation um is telemetry and logging
on our critical infrastructure on our
Telecom uh but also energy water and
really critical infrastructure is mainly
operated by cyber security companies
from abroad they at least have to share
a a carbon copy of their Telemetry and
logging to the National cyber security
centers and why because it's our own
Sovereign space we want to know what is
happening there and also for bounty
hunters and also for the programs that
you've mentioned I think it has to be
done inside it's Sovereign space but if
you look at the critical vulnerabil um
vulnerability disclosure program that is
in the nis2 I think you should be very
happy it's done very responsible we
engage with stakeholders with companies
we we the the aim is to create a safer
internet as such and not think of the
particular interest of a company a
hacker or what you have we want to have
a safer
internet you already mentioned uh the
responsible disclosure uh to working
together with the companies I didn't
find any guard rails that would in some
way also uh protect uh me as a
researcher um for example what if a
company does want not want to disclose
uh publicly this information are the
reports that companies have to share
about incidents um public at some point
by default is there a timeline for when
the public will know or is this only
data that is internally getting used by
Europe well it's a good question and let
me first say something about your first
sentence what we actually did is make
sure that we did include it in a recital
let's let's say to say what does it
article mean it means that hackers like
you who
found vulnerabilities um they can't be
incriminated by the national courts
that's not the meaning they should they
should have leeway they should have
leeway to do their job in a free Manner
and Report those vulnerabilities
responsibly and then in indeed the um
the the manufacturers and that the
software and Hardware developers they
have a responsibility to disclose that
in a in in in in in in a certain
timeline it is it is in there and what
we've tried to do is is set it up um so
that everyone has the time and and the
Rev you to um to to to to have the
patches available whenever anything
comes out like this is a new
vulnerability so that hackers can't
exploit it that easily that is the way
that we want to go
forward there are also a reporting
requirements I read that if a company is
not fulfilling their due diligence they
could be fined it might also make the
managers responsible for that um maybe
you remember the solar winds incident
where we just heard news uh about it
last week in the US where the SEC finded
um the ceso for allegedly lying about
the security posture do you think uh
nstu can prevent something like this
happening in the EU yeah well the first
thing is uh um the fine let me let me
first say something about that the fine
uh we said if you don't have a fine
we've been discussing this for 15 years
in Europe and we said the cyber security
has to be a board issue of every
essential critical entity and of every
company it hasn't no one has succeeded
in making it a board issue now for the
first time like commissioner Breton has
said when we created this legislation
the French commissioner he put forward
this proposal he said it has to have
teeth if a tiger doesn't bite if it
doesn't have teeth the legislation is
not that valuable so we put a personal
liability to a CEO and a liability from
1.4 to 2% of the yearly revenue and why
that number because that's exactly what
ransomware gangs from Russia ask when
they hack you so you have a choice I
either pay to those Russian ransomware
criminals I either pay a fine I'll tell
you more about it or I invest a little
bit in cyber security and I'm much safer
now on on that fine that's not like if
you would have a mistake like in solar
winds that you could be fined in Europe
it's Unthinkable right Unthinkable what
we can do is with oversight bodies be in
a conversation and then have a
conversation about are you doing enough
and that is very different if you have
negligable negligence and it's
demonstrably not taken on board then
someone can find you but that's a long
process something that with solar
whatever you can say they had eal
criteria common criteria certified I
wouldn't say that was was was the case
um in Europe that would be Unthinkable
but what is thinkable if you say I don't
care about European nis2 I don't care
about my cyber security and you have
warning after warning you will get
fined okay so do I have as an individual
to worry about it at what scale um is
there something to see it's only the CEO
there was in in previous versions there
was also the cyber security manager and
I said that's not that's not reasonable
what I do think what will happen Fabian
is that CEOs would say really am I be
liable for another thing I'll I'll I'll
look for an insurance company to ensure
that and what insurance companies do
they would hire people like you and
others we know from the cyber security
community and you know what they would
come in and say this is these are crown
jewels you want to segment this from
that and you don't want a connection
between this and that you want to do
this with password management two Factor
so that's an extra bonus on your
security and I like that I like that
movement so that might extra enhance our
security as a
whole an issue that I personally have
just based on my uh experience with
finding security issues in client
software is that I I find unique
vulnerabilities the vulnerabilities I
find are very difficult to avoid for a
company through regulatory means I would
say because they are just mistakes that
happen uh during development um how can
how can even the companies uh deal with
that and are they um legible um uh no
what's what's the word are they Alle um
for for fines if they have um liable
that's the word thank you for for
mistakes um in in their code what's the
due diligence around that well no and
then let me then make it a little bit
complicated we have two major forms of
legislation in Europe the first is the
nis2 for entities the second is cyber
resilience act which is for products
like hard and software products both
have their own logic and cyber security
also in coordinated vulnerability
disclosure but if you for example in a
vital en entity would have I don't know
Microsoft Exchange um then what the
entity is required to do is report that
to the seert and report it together to
uh Microsoft so that it can be patched
right we know that process in the Cyber
uh resilience Act is different there's a
there's a responsibility for producers
of Harden software to create good
software and if vulnerabilities are
found then immediately with the creator
of that software is is is in a process
um and that's different the the the
critical entities have nothing to do
with that so there's two processes but
what we try to do is align them it's
getting complicated right it's getting
complicated but you know this is the
reality and we're trying to streamline
it as good as we can but we want to make
sure that all vulnerabilities found here
are being reported in a responsible
manner not like in China because as you
know the Chinese vulnerabilities
researchers are not allowed anymore to
go to European contest they are not
allowed to report it to Microsoft they
should report it first to the Chinese
services and this is what worries me
most they are stockpiling uh zero days
stockpiling unknown vulnerabilities
which with which they can hack into
products and essentially in entities and
this is something that I'm worried about
most because this is something that we
cannot really guard ourselves our
resilience is always too low if you
don't know with what they will hack you
and it will be effective anyway the only
thing that we can do is ask our
intelligence services to look more and
more on what the Chinese are doing in
able to attribute and do something about
it on the spot but this is really
becoming more and more of a competition
between intelligence Services than it is
a competition of us being more resilient
against the evil hacker World attacking
us we are almost at the end of time but
I do want to have one last question
because it's still to my heart about the
education aspect related also to what
you just mentioned right now uh there
are hacking competitions as you briefly
mentioned like pwn to own for example
where there are um real life targets
such as phones and looking through the
list of companies and individ idual
participating in these vulnerabilities
and Reporting these none of these are
European companies or individuals I
might have missed one but generally
speaking they are out of Asia or the
Americas so I do wonder how do we bridge
this Gap in Europe that apparently
there's massive skill lacking in the EU
we don't see participants here and um do
you think there's a future like what can
we do here in the you about that well
skills is one of the most is the
important most important agenda that we
have in the digital Europe program and
in other programs um but the second
thing we've created a market for cyber
security with this legislation as well
and in a market demand will grow and
universities will see it's interesting
so more and more universities are
adapting and are offering um Computer
Sciences uh courses and and cyber
security courses and I really commend
that many young youngsters listening and
thinking shall I be studying something
with Computer Sciences yes yes do it
it's wonderful it's beautiful to see how
these machines operate and to really get
the Finesse out of it and really
understand what is going on it it's
rewarding it's nice and there's always
going to be uh a requirement for your
talent so please do so and I think in
Europe we can we can make a fist out of
this but we're not the biggest um zero
day researchers in the world they're
probably in b sha in Israel and they're
probably somewhere in the US and in
China but that doesn't mean that cyber
secur is only about find discovering
research doing research on
vulnerabilities it's also about
protecting companies researching
adversaries doing something on the
government level with private companies
and what we Tred to do was make an
ecosystem that it all works together
also with companies also with other
countries the legal basis is now here in
Europe that's what we created and
there's plenty of work for skilled
people thank you very much I really
loved what you said about uh why people
should study computer science I really
hope that we can improve the cyber
security resilience in Europe um I hope
thatness too will help um for breaches
and incidents to be reported and and and
not shamed but also but but closely
followed and um analyzed for a
datadriven approach uh to SEC cyber
security so thank you very much for your
time and uh I wish you best of luck with
the member states implementing this app
properly you too good luck with your
good work Fabian see you thank
you